hi I'm Seth the Chandler I'm a law
professor at the University of Houston
Law Center and my talk is going to be on
efficient and elegant extraction of data
using the Wolfram language with a focus
on the query command and the data set
structure
okay well thank you very much for coming
and hopefully you can will be able to
see this I'm not sure why you can't see
it but I'm Seth Chandler and I'm going
to be talking about exploring a very
large legal citation Network and I know
you can't read that either basically let
me just start with there's a lot of data
behind this and there's so much data
that I don't even want to try to run
this live so I'm simply going to
describe it for you I anticipate that
the data will be available on the
Wolfram data repository as fuchs soon as
a few issues are ironed out mostly
relating to the size of the data and how
we might want to break it up but there
are gigabytes of data here that are
underlying this so why should you care
most of you I assume are not lawyers and
what I would say is that first of all in
many fields
um so you've got lots of citation
networks out there and some of the
techniques that I'm going to be using
here in algorithmic analysis of these
networks may be useful to you I'm gonna
be doing a little bit of network theory
which might be useful for some you'll
see data set management issues that will
certainly recur anytime we have large
data and I'll also as I was yesterday
showing how one can use the query slash
data set paradigm to do a fair amount of
analysis of large data if anyone in here
is a lawyer we're gonna talk about how
the American judicial system has evolved
and how you can show that
algorithmically okay so this does follow
on some work that I did actually 13
years ago where I was one of the first
people to look at what was then
considered to be a large network which
was the citations between American
Supreme Court cases and that involved
about 28,000 cases and roughly 250,000
links and but time has evolved and now
even Texas alone we now have data from
Texas and that has four hundred and
forty thousand cases and 2.5 million
edges and that's been analyzed and you
can see for example what some of the
most important cases are
or make an exciting word cloud of a
particularly interesting Texas case we
have the Washington University in st.
Louis has been compiling for many years
a large data set
looking at US Supreme Court cases and so
just so you know what can be done I
thought this might be interesting to
some in light of current events is as
many of you know one of the swing
justices on the Supreme Court Anthony
Kennedy retired leading to a big fight
about who would be his replacement and a
purportedly more conservative judge
Brett Kavanaugh was nominated and so one
question was does it really matter as a
practical matter and so what I did here
was to search all five for Supreme Court
decisions since Justice Kennedy was on
the bench in which the court was liberal
but only because Justice Kennedy decided
to cast a liberal vote and I wanted to
see how many cases were like that and as
you can see there are actually quite a
few and particularly in areas of
Criminal Procedure and civil rights
there are a number that's not to say
predict what Cavanaugh will do but it
does suggest that if you are result
oriented you might be concerned about
the substitution on the Supreme Court
all right so what's available now there
are a couple of legal datasets that are
available the Washington University in
st. Louis dataset has been translated
into I think a very nice Wolfram
language e format with entities and all
sorts of fun stuff and on a slightly
related matter if you're interested in
the death penalty there is now a pretty
comprehensive data set on United States
executions since the 1970s when the
Supreme Court permitted it to be
restored all right where's this'll data
coming from I want to give a plug for an
organization called Free dot law which
has been collecting huge volumes of
legal citations and evading cleverly
various ways that people try to make it
more expensive for them to get that
information if you've never read a legal
opinion I just found one here and what
you can see is
that for example here's a case and it's
discussing bla bla bla but here's a
reference to another case and here's a
reference to another case and here's a
reference to another case and so what
one needs to do is to find parsers that
intelligently separate out the citations
from the other stuff in the case and try
to figure out what entity in some sense
it's an entity referencing problem does
that refer to I will say that free dot
law has done a reasonable job on this
but indefinitely an imperfect job in
part because standards for citation in
the United States were not really
unified until the mid 1920s and so
information that was before that it gets
a little tricky so we've got a couple of
data sets that I guess it is only US law
and they have a little bit of Old
English law but nothing much to speak
okay
okay it would be very nice if they would
expand themselves to other common-law
domains Australia has a pretty rich
repository UK has a rich repository
going beyond that you start to get into
language issues and but I think I think
they would be very interested in
expanding so we have two data sets that
they had one was a data set with links
and one was the data set describing the
cases but there was no good connection
between the two so that I might know
that case number 3473
was cited by case 1 million three
hundred and eight thousand but I
wouldn't have any idea what that meant
and so I actually collaborated with them
to try and put together the linking
information and for a very modest
contribution to free dot law they they
went ahead and did it and so I now have
the related data that that I want I will
say the bad news that I've discovered is
that sometimes free means that it may
not be of the highest quality and one of
the things I've been trying to do is to
weed out errors left so for example if a
case from 1920 is citing a case from
2007 that's very unlikely to have
occurred
and so I good chunk of my effort has
been in trying to weed out those kind of
errors anyway here's what the data set
looks like and you'll see there are four
million 117 thousand cases in the whole
thing
we've got all sorts of information on
those cases what is its site we have the
days between the citations of that case
all wrapped up in a nice Wolfram
quantity array we've got a graph which
has is cleaned and after its cleaned it
has three million one hundred and
seventy six thousand vertices and 30
million edges and so from my perspective
we are right sort of at the edge of what
my nice little MacBook Pro can do and I
think one of the issues that I need to
confront and others need to confront is
whether the data set Mathematica in core
capability is really up to this
challenge or whether we need to move to
more sophisticated backends like [ __ ]
or other things that Steven was
discussing last night and any event what
do we find so if there are any lawyers
in the room these are the most cited
cases and you will recognize I would say
most people who have a law degree would
recognize almost all of the top 20 cases
and they are almost all interestingly
enough cases about procedure either
procedure in criminal cases or procedure
in civil cases and so this was at least
refreshing that this was plausible many
of you may know what PageRank is it's
the old algorithm that Google used at
least at first in order to prioritize
things that the search engine hit and
when you do that you find a somewhat
similar list again these are mostly
Criminal Procedure cases some of you may
recognize Miranda versus Arizona or
Gideon versus Wainwright and others
though are of more historic interests
like good old Gibbons versus Ogden from
1824 which has persisted as a really
important case I tried to run hit
centrality and cat centrality to get
other measures and I discovered either
that it blew up the kernel
or in exhausted my patience so all right
so one of the issues also is there are a
number of opinions that are not
technically published they're sort of
out there but you're not supposed to
cite them and so I wanted to get rid of
the unpublished opinions and see if that
was biasing things towards criminal
cases because a lot of them tend to be a
lot of the unpublished cases involve
fairly frivolous prisoner appeals where
you know they got nothing to lose so why
not file an appeal and the answer is no
it didn't really affect very much and so
I don't think that what we see about
Criminal Procedure cases and to some
extent Civil Procedure cases is an
artifact of publication bias that's me
just trying to figure out what it was
all right um I decided I wondered how
many lines of code it would take to
replicate my 2005 work which was this I
will say huge effort involving J link
and Java libraries and this external
program called magic doing that Supreme
Court work in 2005 was quite challenging
and here it all is if I'd only waited
that's what we would have found and the
results although there have been new
citations are largely consistent with
what I saw and I would say that these
are you'll notice these are a little
different set of cases these are cases
where a Supreme Court decision cites
another Supreme Court decision and these
are on a more diverse set of topics many
of which deal with congressional power
to regulate commerce with review of the
ability of the Supreme Court to review
legal decisions made by state courts we
also have other things you know Gideon
versus Wainwright about the right to
counsel marie's let's see I was very
excited to see Maurice let's see which
is about the ability of people who are
not what are called article 3 judges
meaning they don't have life tenure to
actually decide things that are really
important like whether you'll be
deported or not so and what's nice is
that algorithmically we can find that
those cases actually are very important
so one question I had was my goodness
this is a you know this takes time
I'm this this whole thing this is very
big do we really need all this data
maybe we could just sample the edges and
if I sample the edges really the same
cases would come up and so I don't need
to be doing all this work so here's a
little graph and what it shows is the
variation of PageRank based on the
number of samples and so what perhaps
you can see is as we get to a million
edges the relationship between the mean
of the PageRank and the standard
deviation of the PageRank begins to
decline and so at least for the big
cases sampling seems to be okay and
that's probably mostly what we care
about do I really care exactly what the
PageRank is of some you know forgotten
1883 case out of South Dakota probably
not but if I did we see that there is a
lot of variation even with a million
edges all right so another thing we can
do is look at legal history and start
restricting ourselves to see what what
would the law have looked like if I were
say in the mid 60s before what's called
the Warren Court came into effect and
really changed or many people think
changed the direction of American
jurisprudence and an interesting finding
is yeah they really did change the
direction of American jurisprudence if I
look at this list of cases I do not see
Criminal Procedure cases I do not see
Civil Procedure cases I see cases about
Commerce I see case called about
personal jurisdiction by state courts I
see a case about a federal power to
create banks there's a Criminal
Procedure case I see a case about
discrimination a state court review the
privileges and immunities clause and
most a lot of stuff about federalism
actually and so what you can see just
algorithmically is the move from the
time of the Warren Court from a more
diverse concern about issues of
federalism and congressional power to a
much more rights oriented approach in
the more modern era and so I thought
that was an interest
thing that one could tease out I
attempted to go back and see hey if I
were alive in 1900 what would this look
like and what we see is I've never heard
of a lot of these cases and we also have
the curious appearance of North Carolina
I think and I need to track this down I
think the appearance of North Carolina
is bad data at work that is I would be
surprised if suddenly in 1900 everyone
was paying very close attention to the
North Carolina courts but what you also
see is cases that are not particularly
familiar to us today and immodestly I
know a fair amount about legal history
and I don't know a lot of these cases
and so I think part of this is is
actually the result of the inability of
these scrapers to find citations and so
there even though other cases may be
important the links aren't there for the
algorithm to work on okay so what else
did I try there's another program called
I graph em which is a glue between
Mathematica and a python-based graph
program and I wanted to see if it could
do any better or differently like
whether it could run hits centrality
turns out that actually sorry to say
Mathematica I graph em did run this
stuff and so you can see interesting
things so let's talk about something
called anyone know what the degeneracy
of a graph is everything right making
this paper called the evolving
degeneracy of the court system the
degeneracy of the graph is imagine that
every case in some subset of a case
cites at least and other members of that
subset but that if I increase n by one
there is no subset that satisfies that
relationship that n when n that's the
degeneracy of a graph and it's some
measure I think of the complexity of
cases that in order to understand the
seamless web of the law you actually
have to understand a huge body of law in
order to get it there's a lot of
interaction
on and so what we can see here is that
the the actual core that degeneracy of
the graph actually stands at 121 cases
that there are subsets in which in order
to understand the cases you have to
understand 121 others what are they and
interestingly enough there are a lot of
cases from Mississippi mostly on
Mississippi Criminal Procedure and in
particular on Mississippi death penalty
law and for those who practice in that
field as one of my colleagues does it is
a particularly complex area and it makes
at least I will put a little editorial
here which is does it make sense for a
body of law in which usually the people
do not have very many resources to be
one of this great degree of complexity
but I can at least reassure my colleague
that the reason he thinks it's
complicated is because actually it is
really complicated if I looked at the
cake or at the start of the 20th century
it's quite a different picture and our
friend Gibbons versus Ogden which seems
to always appear which is about a
steamship by the way if anyone wants to
know is up there as well as some cases
that frankly once again I do not know
what Davis versus grey is about alright
so one of the other things we can look
at are how two courts relate to each
other are there clusters of courts that
tend to cite each other are there courts
that defer to each other so we can come
up with some notion of power within the
court system and it turns out yeah we
can so we can find the communities of a
court to court graph and we see sort of
a main cluster here of the First Circuit
Court of Appeals which is one level
below the Supreme Court in the federal
system SCOTUS which is the abbreviation
for the Supreme Court of the United
States the Seventh Circuit the Ninth
Circuit the Fourth Circuit the Sixth
Circuit the DC Circuit from whence Brett
Kavanaugh hails the Second Circuit the
Third Circuit and then we get into
various state Supreme Court's in the
like and so this forms one fairly large
cluster of power but we also see
regional clusters like this is I thought
was interesting this is kind
of the New England cluster of New
Hampshire New York Connecticut courts we
see the good old Texas cluster here
Texas Court of Appeals Texas Court of
Criminal Appeals Texas Supreme Court
blah blah blah blah blah New Jersey's in
its own world and so algorithmically you
can see just from the citation patterns
how the communities of Courts decompose
and we can make of course a nice picture
of this showing the patterns of
deference in American law where this
central cluster is basically the Supreme
Court and the lower federal courts right
below it and we have various things
feeding in as well as courts that really
seem to be off on their own like the
Idaho Court of Appeals kind of listens
to the Idaho court but Idaho people
leave it alone so that is the court the
court citations we can also look at what
is the life span of a legal opinion that
is these things have half-lives they
keep getting pinged in ping-ping-ping
but after maybe 30 40 years they've been
supplanted by some other opinion and so
one of the things I wanted to look at
was the differential lifespan of
citations by court and it turns out that
actually it's not so much the power of
the cordon in some traditional hierarchy
it's whether it's at the top of its own
system so the New York Court of Appeals
that's the top court in New York the
Ohio Supreme Court that's the top court
in Ohio the Supreme Court Supreme Court
of Connecticut these are mostly courts
that are at the apex and therefore they
don't have other courts coming in and
stepping over them
whereas courts that are generally
considered to be prestigious like the DC
Court of Appeals or the Ninth Circuit or
the Fifth Circuit the lifespan of their
citations may be less because they are
being stepped on by other courts and so
I thought this was interesting and
thinking about the stability of the law
and if you want to know what's the
average lifespan of a case it's about
nine years that's the half life of a
case about nine years so what else can
we do I'm hoping to use structured
arrays and structured data to get this
data size down because
that has been the main obstacle to doing
stuff it's just really this is data that
at least for me is stretching my
abilities in terms of its size I was
hoping we would have compilation
available to work on associations but I
am told that is going to have to wait I
did some work with [ __ ] Lync which I am
very proud to say actually worked the
only problem was I couldn't if what
didn't seem to be any faster so I
thought the complexity wasn't worth it
and maybe doing some parallelization
with query and data set as I said there
is tons of work to be done here I've
just this is just sort of a it's not at
the level of Steve Wolfram with his n KS
telescope looking at the computational
universe not even close but it's sort of
the same thing as here's this new data
set that's out there that people have
not probed before because they weren't
as nice as I was to free dot law and
what do we see what can we find from
that and so there are various projects
including better integration with other
datasets and I might play around with
seeing if this is suitable for rdf and
sparkle so that's what I got
[Applause]